here here goes Cosmic girl this might
look like a normal airplane plane and
yes we are wheeled up but once it's in
the sky it's clear it's actually a
rocket launch
Richard Branson's virgin orbit made a
big bet on launching satellites from
Airborne 747s it was expected to be a
cheaper and more flexible method than
traditional rocket launches
but that bet hasn't paid off in March
virgin orbit laid off 85 percent of its
staff and filed for bankruptcy in April
a Runway was set and our Runway was was
shorter than when perhaps we needed so
what went wrong
virgin orbit started out as a branch of
Richard Branson's larger space Venture
Virgin Galactic in 2012. Richard Branson
as has Elon Musk as has Jeff Bezos talks
about space as an aspirational goal as
something about which he's passionate
and believes is important Carissa
Christensen is an analyst who has been
working in the space industry for 30
years that aspirational vision is an
unusual part of this business compared
to an awful lot of others in 2012 there
was a growing market for small
satellites they are typically cheaper
and easier to build than larger ones but
launching them was another story most
had to hitch a ride on larger
conventional launches which were
difficult to come by and sometimes
didn't drop the satellite in the right
place so while virgin was developing its
spacecraft for human launches it saw
another opportunity
say hello to launcher one launcher one
was a small launch vehicle that virgin
positioned as a small satellite solution
small launch Vehicles were a fairly
small industry at the time launcher 1
was one of two new vehicles that went
into development in 2012. the investment
thesis being that those small satellites
would value the opportunity to be
launched on a smaller launcher because
they could go where they wanted when
they wanted and the total launch cost
would be lower as Branson told CNN the
current costs about 40 million dollars
Thirty forty million dollars we'll be
able to do it for less than 10 million
dollars virgin planned to achieve this
using that unique method of putting its
rockets on modified Boeing 747s
in typical launches rockets need one of
these a powerful stage one booster to
send it straight up into the atmosphere
before smaller stage 2 engines take over
using a jet presented a faster more
flexible and reusable way to get
launcher one closer to orbit before
detaching to finish the trip no launch
pad required the idea that you could
launch from anywhere and that you would
have flexibility with regard to when you
launched was very attractive and because
you're not competing for launch sites
that was the thought that virgin could
provide that service then in 2017 orbit
spun off of Galactic with former Boeing
executive Dan Hart at the helm but there
was an issue it still hadn't had a
single launch and competition in the
space was growing in 2020 the company
made its first launch attempt but it
wasn't successful some disappointment
that we we didn't get to finish the
flight and and take it to orbit but we
were all prepared for that we collected
an enormous amount of data to bring in
Revenue the company needed to be making
regular launches in the meantime virgin
orbit was burning through cash analysts
estimated the company had spent more
than 400 million developing its launch
system and it looked to raise more then
in January 2021
success launcher once in space the
company deployed 10 small satellites
into orbit for the first time it made
its first commercial launch in June then
go a bit right now are going to
concentrate on on satellites into orbit
and uh and you know and and just ramp up
you know ramp up their capabilities and
ramp up their finances virgin orbit
decided to go public through a merger
with a special purpose acquisition
company or spec an earlier Stage Company
trading publicly has a level of scrutiny
and visibility into what it's doing
that's very challenging for a company at
that stage but the listing didn't
generate the 483 million virgin orbit
was looking for instead it ended up with
less than half that while virgin
continued its launches in 2022 larger
launches were becoming more accessible
new Rideshare options like one with
SpaceX catered to small satellite
companies and advances in technology
made it easier to drop satellites in the
right spot unlike earlier large launches
it really is the taxi versus is a bus if
you take a taxi you'll pay a modest
amount compared to hiring a whole bus
but if you just buy one seat on the bus
it's cheaper than taking the taxi but
orbit still had one major relationship
it could potentially lean on to bring in
more funding the UK space agency the
government entity is a good customer for
small launch and it was important for
the UK because the UK has been expanding
its presence in space and was looking
for an opportunity to conduct launch
from the UK so in January it planned the
first ever launch to take place on UK
soil but it didn't go as planned it
appears that launcher one has suffered
an anomaly which will prevent us from
making orbit for this Mission the
failure caused orbit stock to fall 14
percent that day and it continued to
slide investors are just not as risk
tolerant there's not much Capital
available there are other places for
that Capital to go and so particularly
for a launch business which needs a lot
of capital that becomes a problem
virgin orbits layoffs and bankruptcy
filing followed in the wake of that
failed launch the satellite launch firm
tied to British billionaire Richard
Branson failed to secure the funding
needed to keep operating my point is in
this environment any any execution
failures are just going to be magnified
CEO Dan Hart said in a statement at the
time that the company must do what is
best for the business virgin orbit
declines to comment further for this
video but this isn't necessarily the end
for the company virgin orbit is hoping
to find an investor to buy them out of
bankruptcy I'm optimistic that will find
a partner who wants to take us forward
and for now the company is still
planning more launches